I heard this when I have to ask is it
true that you pulled your mom's tooth
last year like was there not a dentist
available or well okay so are you going
methods
my mother and I were offering your this
this this past summer for six weeks and
oh wow she came around and was like baby
I was like what she said baby
my tooth is hanging by a thread and I
was like all right you want me to pull
this she said yeah baby pull it and so I
just yanked it out of her head oh but uh
that that's it your mama's bold yeah but
it it was it was it was acrylic and
she's
in her head in her mouth for 16 17 years
so it was due to come out yeah and it
was just it was just dangling so I just
pulled it out and so then I sent her to
my dentist and she was like you owe your
dentist three thousand dollars because
you did this because you didn't pull my
truth out right
handles with that right I was like it's
not my fault it was rotten
16 17 years it finally came out and it
was some residue left up in there but
that's between my mom and her dad
I've actually had that happen to me
before and I'm just driving around like
with my friend I'm like oh I was like
and I've only had like three fillings
but one of them just came out and I was
like does this just happen when you
start to get old when it happens yeah
and it was a huge tooth my mother has
like dinosaur teeth all right yeah it
was a big one she probably appreciates
that um
what were you in your mom doing in Italy
you went for six weeks you went for six
weeks in Europe my mother and I we have
uh uh our our own reality show we
haven't come up with the title yet but
it's going to be released this summer on
peacock and it was just us and our
travels throughout Europe yeah we did
London Kent Paris can Leon Venice Rome
Florence and back to London so we did
all that for six weeks that
I did just to have a bunch of people do
that with their yeah dude no no no it's
not a good idea to travel with your mama
for six years
you know
yeah but six weeks nah I was gonna say
I'm about to be in Italy with my mom for
six days yeah then that's cool six days
is the limit yeah that should be the
limit she's really good about it though
my mom is good if I'm like look you
can't keep up so I gotta go but I'll be
back and like she's good about being
like yeah I'll be here with my book like
no no that's not my mama my mama
wouldn't be a part of everything oh well
my mom probably wants to but like look
yeah I want to walk around yeah no my
mom my mama wants to be in the club she
wants to be in the party she wants to do
all that yeah okay yeah that's my mom's
good with a book yeah okay I'm really
happy about that it should be a good
vacation
well there was this photo of your mom
with Janet Jackson and I love this
because it looks like you were kind of
pushed out of the shot like that that's
exactly what happened so uh Janet was in
town so I called my my friend up called
Johnny Gill up with hey man Jan is in
town my mom want to meet Janet so then
Janet had her people call me she said
we're going to be at this club but such
and such I'll be there at midnight 12
30. I said okay so I show up she shows
up at 12 30. yeah I am so not cool yeah
so we get there and my mom was like so I
take it back and it's just Janet myself
uh and my mom and one of Janet's friends
and we're just sitting there and my mom
was like
I was like Mom we just can't take a
picture of Janet I was like I have to
ask her so I was like hey Janet my mom
would love to take a picture which I
would love to take a picture with your
mom so as we're all posing there and I
was like three two one my mama pushes me
out the way
as I I clicked the button that's why I
only got half of my face
and it's been like look at look how
she's smiling like get out of my way
sucker but her teeth look great yeah
that was that was prior to me uh yanking
that rotten one out of her mouth
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]